bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france après plus d'un an
donc 200 relations diplomatiques qu'est
ce qui a poussé et les dirigeants
coréens à reprendre contact est ce que
c'est une volonté d'apaisement avec la
dette anniversaire de la fin de la
guerre de corée style 27 juillet 1953
l'armistice n'ont pas vraiment la fin
des opérations nous pas la fin de la
guerre
les bébés sont encore techniquement en
guerre il n'y a pas eu d'accord de paix
signés en dehors de ça je pense que il y
avait déjà des frémissements 1 puisque
même la corée du sud avait présenté une
candidature pour les jeux olympiques de
il a échoué c'est brisbane et une choisi
mais déjà il y avait quelque chose qui
se passait et là je pense qu'il ya là un
nouveau peut-être au cours de jeux
olympiques même si la corée du nord n'y
participe à un frémissement de relations
dans la région parce qu'il ya de
nombreux déplacements de personnel
politique pas forcément de très haut
niveau mais personne et politiques qui
vont important des américains à pékin
des gens qui se rencontrent en marge des
jeux olympiques avec qui peuvent
discuter
les deux dirigeants ont donc décidé on
l'a vue de restaurer la confiance
mutuelle entre les deux corées dès que
possible et 10 d'avancé à nouveau dans
la relation avancer à nouveau alors on
peut s'attendre à quoi selon vous on
peut espérer que et ne rencontre entre
directement physiquement entre les deux
dirigeants qui est encore des
pourparlers sur les différentes
modalités de passage de l'un à l'autre
une restauration physique aussi de
choses peuvent été démolie à
l'initiative de la corée du nord ou
adjoints de l'année dernière où un point
de communication des moyens de travail
commun tous à petit à petit va peut-être
va peut être évoluer
et puis il ya des propositions les
américains entre les propositions pour
revenir à des voire plus diplomatiques
pratique ce qu'avait fait le président
trump donc peut-être que ces progrès ont
retrouvé deux corées pourrait paver la
voie pour une heure
contre avec des états unis qui re
demeure le principal problème quand même
en parler pour la corée du nord
est ce que on peut dire aussi que la
crise économique due à la pandémie de
kovy de 19 qui fait rage aussi en corée
du nord aurait pu pousser qu'ils ont ou
n'a relancé donc cette diplomatie dans
la région mais aussi avec les états unis
il est vrai depuis maintenant plus de 20
ans que la crise sur tige eux avec des
armes nucléaires avec des en balistique
et autres en corée du nord les les
propositions les avancées dans un sens
ou dans un autre mais la sortie du
chemin classique du milieu par la corée
du nord sont liées à des à des chantages
wade demande pour aider la corée du nord
sont pas économiques qui sembleraient se
prouver en ce moment au kilo médiation
plus difficile est-ce qu'on voit on peut
voir aussi la volonté de pyongyang
aussi toujours avec cette pandémie la
volonté d'obtenir un allégement des
sanctions internationales semblerait
qu'effectivement ces sanctions
internationales font mal et un
allégement permettrait de mieux
fonctionner ville inviteront de son
peuple qu'il a il faut quand même voir
que joue le par rapport à son pote est
quelqu'un qui a une aura extraordinaire
était le père du peuple
si le peuple a faim est vraiment très
fin à ce moment là il perd de sa
légitimité vis à vis à vis vraiment de
sa population et remercie beaucoup pour
toutes ces précisions jean vincent
brisset je rappelle que vous êtes
directeur de recherche à l'iris merci à
vous